we've all enjoyed it's working mom
Breaking Bad NCIS How I Met Your Mother
and more and now on pop Network let's
get physical' premiering Wednesday
January 24th with Jane Seymour AnnaLynne
McCord
David resetti and Matt Jones good to see
you sir thanks you're most welcome
thanks for being here so you as a Bears
fan yeah are where does a Bears fan sit
in on the I guess what's the word for to
the schadenfreude oh that everybody
feels towards the Brady well cuz hey
situation with the Patriots right now
everybody loses their quarterbacks it's
a thing but just the goal of the
Patriots for so long to just he never
gets hurt I mean he did one year yeah I
mean off and on and they've still won 11
games exactly and it's just they could
still win with Brian Hoyer is the
problem what I was hoping is I want them
to sign Colin Kaepernick and I want the
world to explore wins a Super Bowl and
then everybody just get Brady's home
Brady's hand can't can't can't go I know
that right now by the end of the day
Kaepernick is in New England and he
learns the offense and time to beat
Blake bortles somehow and then he shows
up at the biggest NFL event there is as
the quarterback of the New England Paige
yeah I don't know if that's gonna happen
I think the Patriots are also like the
Empire you know like you know the guy
the guy not Vader the most said the
Emperor that is absolutely yeah he's
poverty and Brady is Vader okay and and
he somehow sold his soul in some way and
I think that his hands are starting to -
mmm sure there's like scales or
something was so like he's the the deal
he made with the devil is now coming
back around and it's it's right at the
last moment well let's keep workshopping
this yeah because if you weird cuz now
he's in the same division where does
Cutler fit into all that stuff I don't
where does he fit he doesn't fit
anywhere I don't want him anymore
I feel bad for Miami I don't even like
Miami and I feel bad for I just I can't
I can't
you couldn't even root for J no no why
would I why why I don't know cuz he gave
he gave you he gave out of seven years
he gave us probably three years like
that's his his giv level hmm yeah I'm
not I'd like to forget the that'll have
been kidding yeah you know who got us
further rex grossman yeah well you could
say Urlacher was part of that defense
right lazy Greg sexy Rexy just didn't
have to turn it off hidden but we
definitely grew tired yeah we didn't
have a lot of receivers at that point we
didn't have a lot of we had a many holes
on offense I'm just saying by the way I
just spent the last 10 seconds of my my
time here defending Jay Cutler yeah I
you Matt Jones yeah well well I mean so
what do you think of the current moves
that the Bears have made I'm really
excited about you are I am okay I'm
cautiously optimistic which is a Bears
fan okay but I think naggy swaggy Maggie
is what good okay I like the way he
talks I don't know we're so used to
people that don't really talk much like
um
lovey doesn't say much you love you
didn't say much Marc Trestman didn't say
much John Fox I just wasn't listening
I like the movies are making it's
interesting I'm interested with this guy
from Morgan's gonna do yeah Halpert you
bring him in yeah well they're gonna
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
bring like a spread out run pass option
for true Biscay yeah and with Tariq Coen
maybe having the ball or Howard has the
ball or three cones that that new Darren
Sproles type there you go he's fantastic
I I think there's a lot there
we just need to draft a cornerback and
some wide receivers that said how many
picks do the Bears have it do that Matt
Jones here on the Rich Eisen show okay
so you you you like what
you think you believe in true Biscay
true Barsky I'm cautiously optimistic
in other words yeah but I think he's got
something I don't know he at least looks
like he's trying and enjoying himself
and working hard which is something
we're not used to you were scarred by
Jay Cutler I really am I just I wanted
to like you know what bears jerseys I
have please I have a Julie's Peppers
okay and I really like that kid a couple
years ago what's his name Johnny Knox
and like right oh my like broke his back
I could never buy a kite again right no
matter how big of a Fanny was I couldn't
bring myself to do it cuz I knew it was
a lie you just couldn't do it I couldn't
do it it's because of that story you
told here a few years ago oh right
a friend of mine they go please this is
this is a guy I knew in Chicago said
that he was in a bathroom and he went to
Vanderbilt and he walked in and Jay
Cutler was like peon and he goes oh hey
man I'm a big fan I went to Vanderbilt
as well and Jay great because I mean
that is literally everything he is he
just doesn't care
I mean it is the biggest violation
though to approach anybody while they're
doing their business let's show right
sure I was in a bathroom once and I'm
guys like I'm a cop I want to take a
picture with you and him and his three
cop friends brought me into a stall and
we all took a picture together and I
didn't feel like I had a choice did you
feel violated
I did those guys can do now I just I uh
yeah
don't talk to people while the PA
there's that and I guess that won't but
and we'll having you know dinner or
whatever so uh it is by the way you
brought this up before is the 10th
anniversary of Breaking Bad
can you believe that it was ten years
ago that it debuted in 2000 and I guess
it has been 10 so when did when were you
when did you
first get approached to play badger I
auditioned and shot my first episode in
October 2007 days oh yeah and then we
went out and I shot I was supposed to
only I was supposed to do two episodes
and after the first episode they call
Vince calls me he goes hey yo there's
gonna be a writer strike so we can only
do seven episodes and so you can only do
one episode and we're gonna have you
introduce Aaron to Tuco that's what I
was supposed to do but nobody believes
that you're mean enough to know somebody
like Tuco because you're you you ended
up being tuned to of a sweet character
so I just did it and then I went home
and I was like who knows what'll happen
it was on AMC's a show about meth with a
guy from malcolm in the middle' like
nobody knew anything but then we uh and
then it like became this supernova over
time it was just crazy what's this one
scene that you can't believe you did or
were part of or one scene I can't or you
were scared like actually legitimately
concerned you mmm that you were asked to
do as a human being on planet Earth yeah
I'm not sure they're they were really
good about that they didn't really push
me too far other people but probably
that I remember the very first episode
we shot there's this montage of us like
eating and drinking while we're making
meth and like this like goofy montage
doesn't make us make you mad and I'd
like drink a 40 huh and I was like hey
guys roll it and I'll down a hole 40 in
one take and I downed the whole thing in
one take like I can drink like that huh
and I did it and they're like that was
great can you do it again I was like
okay and I did it again
and I immediately threw up right right
off-camera is there like a lot yeah okay
yeah yeah we've had that experience on
this show before yeah but it was fine
that I'm sure it was and let's get
physical' looks like a ton of fun yeah I
did aerobics for six weeks in Halifax
Nova Scotia and they filmed it so yeah
yeah you look good I lost 25 pounds
during the show because you're playing
the
son of a fitness legend right yes and
you've lost your your ability to do
anything physically well is that
essentially what it is you've lost your
way on the show my dad is like a fitness
guru and I was not interested in that so
I went off and became a terrible what do
you call a cover band person I'm singing
Guns & Roses in the pilot I sing a lot
in the show too it's a strange but um I
he dies and he leaves his whole fortune
to me but the only way I can get his
fortune is if I compete in a national
aerobics competition and that's what the
whole season is about is me competing in
this competition and your mom is played
by Jane Seymour yeah and my arch nemesis
is Christian Montopolis like Silicon
Valley and jerk
all that stuff and he's fantastic and
it's about him and I really butting
heads
now you said during the TV only segment
that Jane Seymour has got some of the
greatest Hollywood stories of all time
what do you have for me Oh
oh boy that you can choose to own this
like castle ish kind of place an abbey I
don't know what's calling in England
that she would rent out to people and
she rented it out to Radiohead and they
recorded okay computer there and she
said the cure cup recorded a couple
albums there she's like I don't know
there's a lot of people in that time
lots of the Cure Radiohead yeah yeah
yeah a lot of those kind of stories or
like that we're talking about like how
she was hanging out with Prince Harry
and I don't know I was like just cuz
you're British doesn't mean you actually
know the Royals but she does so yeah
did you didn't tell her the Jay Cutler
story like they're like hey you know
somebody who knew Jay Cutler I she does
not care about
[Laughter]
god at Matt Jones is dead on Twitter
next Wednesday at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time
let's get physical with Matt Jones good
to see you yeah thanks anytime come back
anytime the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience